well I'm not sure I mean I thought at
the outset the conservatives were going
to go very strong on the economy but
what happened was that labor more or
less matched it and said well if you're
going to be tough we can be tough also
and then of course the Conservatives
wanted to move it onto the NHS and the
additional spending as did the lib dems
and with each was trying to take the
others kind of pot high policy positions
so what we've ended up with is a very
long campaign where different issues
have been discussed but where it's it's
quite difficult for the parties to have
given clear differences between them and
their rivals I suppose the exception
would have to be you Kip where it's
trying to make great store in terms of
its too strong issues which is
immigration and Europe but no one else
has really kind of listened to very much
of that debate and its failed really to
elevate those two issues as central to
the entire campaign and the top issue
according to the opinion polls pretty
much throughout the campaign has been
the National Health Service yes and and
of course that was what was so good
about the conservative strategy early on
in terms of you know they call for
additional spending on the NHS and we
think that's a good thing they've been
not terribly clear about where that
money would come from in terms of you
know where the where the actual funding
would be from but I thought it was quite
a clever move early on in the campaign
to try and pull the rug if you like from
underneath labour which traditionally
has been campaigning hard on that
particular issue now looking at the
opinion polls say more polls tonight we
won't go into them but basically they
show the same thing labour and
conservatives tied somewhere below 35
percentage I can't recall a campaign
when there's been so little movement it
is quite fascinating isn't it how little
movement there's been and either that
can sit on with some pollsters the
Conservatives slightly ahead of labor
with other pollsters it's the other way
around and some reporting the dead heat
and very very little movement you know
two or three percentage points the odd
poll has seen a leap for one party but
that the next poll has tended to bring
them back again and what about this
theory that there are shy voters you
don't tell the voters that the posters
the truth whether shy Tory
hi kippers well this really dates back
to nineteen ninety two in particular
where the poles either had labor
slightly ahead or the conservatives and
labour neck and neck and of course john
major in 1992 led the national vote by
seven clear percentage points and the
polls were wrong and everyone remembers
that particularly the pollsters and
therefore you know it always goes back
down to if there's no movement in the
polls maybe it's shy Tories now the
first big drama tonight tomorrow night
is going to be at ten o'clock when the
polls close we're going to get the exit
poll for all the broadcaster's you're
working on that and that is very
different from the day-to-day newspaper
polls and should be much more precise
well hopefully the it is different
because it's not at a national opinion
poll what we do is we sample voters in
particular areas particular polling
stations and what we're trying to do is
have a lot of voters about 20,000 it
will be and as they leave the polling
station and ask them how they voted and
what we're trying to do is put together
a forecast to understand what's
happening in the different kinds of
areas and from that generate a national
forecast in terms of seats so it doesn't
talk about a national version doesn't
ask people why they voted that way it
simply asked them how Michael I look
forward to that ten o'clock tomorrow 20